hey dr. Berg here in this video we're
going to talk about the most common
cause of disease what I believe is the
real underlying root issue and yes you
guessed it it's sugar but let me just
explain the mechanism what occurs in the
body the average person in the u.s.
consumes a hundred and forty pounds of
sugar in their diet every single year
but that doesn't even count the hidden
sugars from the breads pasta cereal
crackers biscuits while waffles wine
alcohol baby food it's in everything I
mean that's just outrageous so what
happens is all that sugar gets into your
bloodstream and then there's a hormone
called insulin and what it does is it
basically just pulls the sugar out of
the blood and insulin is made by a gland
called the pancreas now the pancreas has
these little cells called beta cells
right beta cells are the cell that makes
the insulin that lowers the sugar it
gets the sugar out because you're too
much sugar is deadly our bodies were
never designed to consume that much
concentrated sugar I had a patient come
in the other day
she's consuming two liters of juice a
day at another patient consuming a
six-pack of soda every single day not
every single week and they're not even
eight ounces they're actually 12 ounces
or 6 12 ounce sodas a day I don't know
how she's alive that it's our bodies
just are not designed to consume that
much jet fuel and what happens is it
really puts stress on this cell this
beta cell here because it's constantly
like pumping out tons and tons and tons
of insulin so over time what happens is
that the the receptor that's supposed to
kind of take in the insulin so receptors
not receiving it actually starts to
become very resistant of insulin so what
what happens with the sugars it all
occurs in the liver so there's a lot of
insulin sugar metabolism in the liver
and so goes in the liver
it locks into the liver through receptor
and is supposed to create a certain
effect like lowering of sugar right well
what happens you eventually end up with
something called diabetes type 2 which
is a lesser problem than type 1 type 1
is more serious type 2 is less serious
but it's still considered disease so
diabetes type 2 is simply too much it's
a high sugar situation is too much sugar
in the blood so they label you as
diabetes type 2 now what happens really
is your body is simply trying to reject
this insulin by causing the receptor to
stop receiving insulin okay so that's
what diabetes type 2 it's really a
receptor problem in the liver it's
rejecting insulin it's saying I don't
want enough I had enough it's like if
you have people talk to you too much and
you're close you're something's like
talk to the hand don't talk to me
anymore that's what's really happening
and so what happens now the answer sugar
goes up and that's very dangerous
because you can have a coma you can have
all sorts of mental cognitive issues
you're going to be irritable you're
going to be tired you're going to have
nerve problems and vision problems and
there's a lot of side effects so you're
going to belly fat cholesterol high
blood pressure goes right down the list
okay so that's pretty much what happens
at this level
alright so now they're labeled as
diabetes type 2 by the doctor and then
they're treated by either metformin or
glucophage which are the same thing
metformin is comes from a an herb called
goats roux but you can't patent go
through so they basically synthesize and
synthetically and then they basically
met they actually created metformin what
metformin does is all it does is it
makes this receptor receive the insulin
better so basically what it does is it
makes this connect better that's all it
does but it's it's kind of forcing your
body to connect when it shouldn't and
that's the problem that's why it gives
side effects so if
people take too much metformin they can
get a condition called lactic acidosis
that's a fancy word for you're getting
too much acid in your blood and you're
depriving your not depleting your oxygen
so if you can envision working out
really hard and your muscles get full of
lactic acid and you can't you can't
breathe anymore because you're out of
breath and you're huffing and puffing
and that's the same thing at lactic
acidosis occurs in the blood so you
decrease oxygen and you're going to have
all sorts of hyperventilation and
breathing problems that's one of the
side effects with metformin and there's
another side effect called liver failure
and kidney failure so these things don't
come without side effects right now
what's very very very sad is there's not
this connection between what you put in
your body in your diet
and the correction of this issue instead
it's the labeling and the treatment the
management of symptom over time it's not
very profitable to make this link and to
actually have the person stop eating all
this sugar it's much more profitable
than manage the symptom and continue the
diet I would say 9 out of 10 patients
coming in have not been changing your
diet the doctor to really talk about
diet change other than portion control
now if you look at the American Diabetes
Association I think it's called Diabetes
org they have the I think it's the 7
myths of diabetes and this is like
almost comical they said myth number one
sugar caused diabetes they said that's a
myth all right
they said it's a myth that starches will
cause diabetes and it goes on on a
listen you can go ahead and read it it's
ridiculous and the problem is that
they're there they're assigning cause to
obesity like obesity is causing this
diabetes as the culprit and what they're
telling you is genetic or there's
environmental factors and obesity is a
risk factor it's linked to obesity so
there's really no cause effect it's
mainly there's risk factors its genetic
we don't really know yet it's the causes
unknown we don't understand this so
unfortunately the the American Diabetes
Association is
funded it was in the past I don't know
if it's still being funded 23 million
dollars by the pharmaceutical companies
and the food manufacturing company so we
know that that credibility has been lost
just from that funding link but the
point is that this whole link here is
ignored and they'll pretty much tell you
that we do recommend you reduce some of
the juices that you consume but not for
the sake of the insulin problem or the
sugar problem but because of portion
control because their whole thing is to
lower the calories so you see the
confusion what they're doing I mean it's
so so classic so if you have diabetes if
you want to prevent diabetes if you have
family that you care about and friends
you care about please show them this
video teach them these simple concepts
but this is the underlying source of
diabetes and then eventually it wears
out and goes into type 1 diabetes in
which basically they have to be injected
by insulin and if we come back over here
to the pancreas type 1 is basically the
complete exhaustion and breakdown on the
beta cell and so now you don't produce
any insulin in it anymore okay so that's
pretty much the simplicity of the most
common cause of disease and got to get
the junk out of the trunk get the sugar
out of the trunk and definitely you know
spread the word this is dr. Berg I hope
this helped